I can't tell a story about taking this shit without 90 people hitting me up the
next day telling me that was the most brilliant story in the world.
Want to send it to Tom and I?
Tom,
I tell her ain't on the shit.
Kind of make it.
Oh my God.
That was dumb.
I took a shit in favor in his backyard after a five hour drive from Colton or
some weird town.
Did he not talk to you after that for awhile I took a shit and then he ran over
it with his car and the whole back yard smartly.
I go,
what did that meg a day he goes,
it smells back here.
Let's walk in the house.
I don't know what happened.
As you can see the brown shit smooshed it with this tire and a bunch of flyers.
Talk to me for a month after that in some of these backyards
because I told him the truth.
I felt bad,
but I lied to the guy
that's hard to clean up too.
Wow.
Yeah.
Shit.
You can clean up dog shit.
It doesn't mean make you gag,
but human shit bomb shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
it smells so much stronger,
man.
It's so much.
No,
no,
no.
Take a shit until you cut it in half,
right.
No one that fucking,
I think it was that Reese's peanut butter fume leaks out.
Oh my God.
He's like,
I've done studies.